the ladies of the view have an important
lesson to teach you about the power of
the
AR-15 and its uses in hunting I would
love to see an assault weapons ban like
President Reagan I don't believe there a
sport or hunting um uh instrument it's
like shooting fish in a bucket but
that's my but also if you shoot with an
AR-15 let's say you shoot a deer you
can't eat it because you basically Dem
in addition to that but the Hunt is
about an actual difficult process not
massacring bodies of any kind but my
point is I'd love to see that Joy bayar
seems to be confusing an AR-15 with a
rocket launcher she she seems to be
confusing an AR-15 with a landmine that
would just explode the deer ironically
she's somewhat correct in what she said
she said if you shoot a deer with an
AR-15 you won't be able to eat it and
that might be true because the deer
might get away